[Music]
I have completed 43 years serving this
nation I have worked for every type of
military aircraft that is flying in this
country in some form or the other I have
worked with every major integrated
defense program whether it is electronic
warfare program or whether it is
integrated guided missile development
program of late s Dr Abdul
kamam I'm a re of best citizen of India
award in 2011 I also have received Glory
of India award in 2013 I was selected
for the Rajiv Gandhi National Excellence
award and I have been a nominee for
padmashri
twice hello I'm Commander yv Prasad I
did a program in the recent past having
enrolled myself for the postgraduation
in the cyber security I'm deeply
satisfied with my
association with simply learn the
hackers mindset how to defend the
hackers mindset and the various
technology policies and the laws which
are there in the Cyber today the cyber
warfare program with reference to how to
defend in number of ways I did not do it
for any kind of resume building or for
any career purpose I did it purely for
my own learning and simply learn
supported me all the defense personnel
must actually go through this particular
certification process and especially for
those who are working in the software
field in defense sector there is no
system today which is not software
software loaded so therefore there is a
responsibility cast on all of us to
ensure that the systems are well
protected never hacked by any kind of
foreign Nationals and enemy Nationals
particularly and we have to be very
careful in developing the software to
such kind of Standards it's essential
that the entire software development is
completely cyber security safe and I
recommend to all the defense personnel
to actually Avail this particular course
to Simply learn today the Warfare is no
longer only missiles and the gunshots
the Warfare is today very imminent in
the form of cyber warfare and that can
stop us that can completely stop the
entire nation think of all the software
systems coming to a halt whether it is
banking whether it is the transport
sector whether it's energy sector power
sector how do we defend ourselves that
becomes important so it is not the guns
it is your knowledge in the cyber
security that is going to defend the
country in future so I recommend
strongly that people become aware of the
essentials of the cyber security and
have the requisite awareness J
[Music]
Hind